as you can see the interior has been
decorated just as you like it in the
Icelandic primitive style oh oh and of
course you love clowns so I do love
clowns now let me show you the video
system here you can review everything
that happened in your life from your
point of view
oh yeah this is your human rights
mission to Ukraine I mean you got a ton
of points for that might really put you
over the top
GD come on in Eleanor I I'm GD Anna
Gagne and you are my soul mate excuse me
I have other people to attempt - so
where you from G I was born in Nigeria
raised in Senegal but my work took me
all over the place Australia Hong Kong
Paris what about you uh Wow I was born
in Phoenix Arizona and then I went to
school in Tempe Arizona and then I moved
back to Phoenix Arizona
your English is amazing oh I'm actually
speaking French this place just
translates whatever you say into a
language the other person can understand
so it's incredible Wow and now I want to
say this okay
Eleanor I have spent my entire life in
pursuit of fundamental truths about the
universe and now we can actually learn
about them together as soul mates it's
overwhelming
Chiti you'll stand by my side no matter
what right of course I will promise me
say I promise I will never betray you
for any reason
Eleanor I swear that I will never say or
do anything to cause you any harm
good because those aren't my memories I
wasn't a lawyer I never went to the
Ukraine I hate
clowns there's been a big mistake I'm
not supposed to be here wait what
you